exhibition that you can enjoy here at
the shops at crystal um so let's now
talk about the fact that you have the
first black barbie here you have the
very first barbie ever made in 1959 here
at the front so you'll have to come down
to see her she's beautiful
and then of course we also have the
famous bob mackie
partnership here with surprise the
legendary frank mourinho now he's going
to tell you why he's here and why we're
standing at bob mackie well bob mackie
does all the show all the gowns that i
wear in the legend show so all the bob
mackie gowns here are very inspirational
towards me i had my own anniversary doll
come out let's show it let's show it off
the show i am a huge
barbie fan yes yes barbie enthusiast and
and what has barbie done for you growing
up until now
well you know what i like about barbie
is because from the very beginning they
started diversity they also did you know
different body style barbies so it was
very inclusive for everybody from the
early days so they were like the
innovators of making everybody feel like
one big world i love that and of course
the dress up we love that right the
dress that we listen i play dresses
every day it is the best thing it keeps
you happy absolutely well christy come
join us again let's talk about how
people can come enjoy the
exhibition and how they can do that sure
we're here at the shops at crystals you
can go online to barbieexpo.com
and then you can also get tickets on the
first level and make sure to take that
photo at the barbie box on the second
level and we're here on level three oh i
love it and just last but not least you
know when they do come here they're not
just seeing the barbies they're actually
learning about them too right absolutely
so many fun facts and just
a lot of ways to see that you can be
anything that has always been barbie's
campaign and i think everybody kind of
shares a different nostalgia and
connection to barbie so it's nice to
kind of bring that inspiration back ooh
and my fun nostalgia i was in a wnba
barbie commercial
what i know i know fun fact you guys
i'll send it back to you